[Musique]
bonsoir nouvelle semaine d'information
locale sur tv 78 bienvenue dans cette
édition spéciale du lundi 30 mars
le coronavirus continue de faire des
victimes partout en france et dans les
yvelines selon des données de santé
publique france disponible sur le site
du gouvernement
soixante neuf personnes sont décédées
depuis le début de la crise sanitaire
dans les hôpitaux du département et dans
les yvelines
on compte en tout 5 159 hospitalisations
liées aux kovy 19 d'après des chiffres
arrêtés hier dimanche
125 personnes étaient encore hier en
réanimation dans le territoire des
statistiques qui augmente mais les
retours à domicile suite à une
amélioration de l'état de santé eux
aussi progresse or ni les plus de 800
victimes francilienne du coc vide 19
patrick devedjian le président du
conseil départemental des hauts-de-seine
est décédé dans la nuit de samedi à
dimanche à l'hôpital privé d'antony et
ville où il fut maire pendant 18 ans
l'ancien député ministre et secrétaire
général de l'ump était engagée depuis
2007 dans un processus de fusion avec le
département des yvelines en quatre ans
plusieurs services et compétences
départementales ont d'ailleurs été
mutualisés une démarche menée avec son
homologue et des yvelines pierre bédier
patrick devedjian avait 75 ans le
président du conseil départemental des
yvelines pierre bédier a d'ailleurs été
l'un des premiers à réagir via un
communiqué le décès de patrick devedjian
est une terrible nouvelle selon lui il
était un ami un grand serviteur de la
france qu'il aimait passionnément
autre réaction à vous proposer au sein
de l'assemblée départementale des
yvelines celle de joséphine coleman
bergé vice présidente en charge de
l'environnement de la culture et du
tourisme elle est également mère de
plaisir j'ai eu du mal à y croire parce
que quand on connaît patrick devedjian
avec toute cette énergie toute cette
gérer cette disponibilité et toute cette
vie qu'il avait en lui ça paraît très
étonnant moi j'avoue que j'ai pris un
coup vraiment dans l'estomac
si je peux me permettre l'expression
parce que c'est quelqu'un que j'ai
croisé plusieurs fois ou bien évidemment
puisqu'il et travaille avec beaucoup
avec nous vous le savez dans le
rapprochement du 92 78 et donc j'ai eu
l'occasion de rencontrer très souvent
avec entre autres le président du
département des yvelines monsieur pierre
bédier
douzième de permanents avec je dirais
une vision de demain de l'avenir qui me
paraissait tellement judicieuse est
tellement évidente par rapport à tous
ces grands projets que nous avions avec
avec le 92 et puis aussi un homme de
culture vous doutez bien que moi c'est
quelque chose qui me touche profondément
en plus c'était un homme qui était très
attaché à la culture ce soit la peinture
la musique l'opéra et plus
particulièrement tout ce qui était à
trait à la culture italienne donc voilà
par mes origines j'avoue que j'avais une
grande sensibilité par rapport à sare et
échappe pas qu'on se rencontraient en
échanger sur nos passions communes
c'est à dire eh bien la passion de la
culture et d'ailleurs on a pu voir avec
la scène musicale combien il a souhaité
développer la culture au niveau du 92
elle a côtoyé patrick devedjian depuis
ses débuts en politique et lorsqu'elle
était adhérente des républicains mais
surtout comme présidente de la région
ile de france l'ancien député des
yvelines valérie pécresse se souvient
d'une personnalité flamboyante et très
cultivé écoutez j'ai été bouleversée
parce que je l'avais pas répond pas il
ya quelques jours et j'étais les
nouvelles itérations et donc ça a été un
très grand choc d'apprendre que son état
s'était subitement aggravé patrick
devedjian c'était une personnalité
flamboyante c'était quelqu'un d'assez
atypique inclassable très original et
donc moi l'image que je garderai de lui
c'est le parce qu'il adorait l'histoire
et donc moi c'est ce patrick devedjian
extraordinairement cultiver ce patrick
devedjian qui aimait vraiment
profondément à la fois la france mais
aussi la remanier la patrie de ses
ancêtres dont je veux me souvenir
et puis dernière réaction à vous
proposer celle de plusieurs
personnalités politiques via leurs
comptes twitter à commencer par gérard
larcher yvelinois président du sénat
grande tristesse de sa part l'ancien
maire de
embrouillé salue un homme courageux et
totalement dévoué à sa ville d'antony et
son département des hauts de seine un
homme d'engagement profondément sincère
ce rappel aurore bergé député de la 10e
circonscription des yvelines celle qui a
rendu récemment un rapport sur la
culture cite par exemple le projet de la
scène musicale portée par patrick
devedjian
de son côté jean michel fourgous met en
avant le grand député-maire le président
de saint quentin en yvelines et maire
d'elancourt on n'oubliera pas le
visionnaire est territorial qu'il a été
et puis à gauche la réaction de l'ancien
député des yvelines et conseiller
municipal de trappes benoît hamon le
fondateur du mouvement générations se
souvient d'un homme intelligent courtois
et plein d'humour
je vous le disais tout à l'heure patrick
devedjian se battaient pour faire
aboutir la fusion des yvelines et des
hauts-de-seine ce processus a été lancé
en 2016 avec pierre bédier s'est
poursuivie avec la mutualisation de
plusieurs services et de des deux
départements
retour sur ce dernier engagement
politique avec nicolas landry c'était
son combat politique actuelle la
création d'un nouveau département issu
du rapprochement des yvelines et des
hauts-de-seine
cette fusion patrick devedjian l'espérer
d'ici à la fin 2020 un voeu commun avec
le président du département des yvelines
pierre bédier rappelé lors d'une
cérémonie le 14 janvier dernier à la
scène musicale de boulogne-billancourt
eh bien écoutez si vous n'avez pas
compris que notre souhait principal
c'était d'obtenir enfin cette fusion que
nous avons engagées may en tenant il y a
trois ans et avec 90% de nos élus et qui
va un peu transformé la vie quotidienne
de nos concitoyens ce projet est lancé
en 2016 par les présidents des deux
collectivités
une création acté au mois de mars à
travers un établissement public
interdépartemental yvelines hauts de
seine on n'est pas encore dans une
fusion
on est simplement dans un processus de
rapprochement
nous avons un instrument pour travailler
ensemble et déterminer ce que pourra
être dans l'avenir une fusion si nous
réussissons à la mener à son terme
plusieurs compétences sont mutualisés
l'archéologie préventive le service
adoption et l'entretien des routes
départementales
viennent ensuite la création d'un
aménageur urbain commun baptisé site
alios ou encore dernièrement la
transformation d'activité en une agence
d'insertion inter départementale on
prend ce qu'il ya de mieux dans le
département qui est là le mieux traités
par exemple nous dans les hauts-de-seine
on a beaucoup gagné au système
d'insertion des yvelines et donc nous
nous avons harmonisé nos deux
dispositifs et nous prenons celui des
yvelines qui est meilleur que le nôtre
efficacité de l'action publique liberté
des collectivités locales des valeurs
défendues par patrick devedjian dans son
parcours politique
suite à sa disparition pierre bédier à
l'espoir de poursuivre le combat de son
homologue alto séquanais sur la fusion
et le dossier de la métropole du grand
paris il était mon ami ensemble nous
avons porté le combat pour une métropole
parisienne digne de ce nom c'est à dire
rayonnante ambitieuse juste et pour le
rapprochement de nos deux départements
si complémentaires honorer sa mémoire
c'est poursuivre son combat pour être
officialisé la fusion des deux
départements doit être décrétée par le
gouvernement dans le contexte actuel la
question pourrait être tranchée qu'en
fin d'année voire en 2021 avec la
disparition de patrick devedjian quid de
la fusion entre les yvelines et des
hauts-de-seine écoutez les explications
de patrice carmouze directeur de la
rédaction de tv 78 il revient aussi sur
les relations qu'entretenaient patrick
devedjian avec nicolas sarkozy
ce qui est intéressant aussi ce sont ses
relations avec eux avec nicolas sarkozy
comme lui il a il s'est prononcé pour
balladur contre chirac aux élections
c'est au ciel comme lui il est aux côtés
hauts-de-seine d'ailleurs il a succédé à
nicolas sarkozy à la présidence du
conseil général 10 ans et
départementales on dit maintenant les
déroutes scène et puis qu il a il l'a
soutenue évidemment nicolas sarkozy
présidentielle il s'attendait sans doute
à être mieux récompensé que l'a été et
d'espérer devenir garde des sceaux
ministre de la justice et il a hérité
juste de l'ump encore pas comme
président parce que sarkozy veut garder
la présidence comme secrétaire général
et je pense qu'il ya un sacré chez lui
une sorte de déception dans sa vie
politique nationale et c'est pour ça que
vous soyez un délire de sa phrase vous
savez comme quoi quand il ya des gens de
gauche qui sont entrés dans le
gouvernement de nicolas sarkozy dit
ouais moi je suis pour l'ouverture je
serais même pour que dit colas europe
sarkozy court jusqu'au sarkozystes ce
qui pouvait bien cette seule sa
déception
il faut être assez fort qu'il faut
combattre eu un peu l'état il faut
combattre
peut-être un peu la région qui voient ça
d'un mauvais oeil ce qu'ils veulent
le promouvoir le grand paris aussi et
qui voit aussi d'un mauvais oeil
deux grands départements se se fusionner
donc il va falloir peut-être trouvé
aussi une personnalité qui soit à la
hauteur de pierre bédier et qui continue
à porter ce cette fusion c'est pas gagné
en record je pense que ça se fera mais
ça va pas être évident de remplacer
patrick de belgique
en tout cas les deux collectivités
poursuivre le travail mutuelle au sein
de l'établissement public
interdépartemental
en cette période de crise sanitaire
yvelines et hauts-de-seine met en place
un dispositif d'urgence pour accompagner
la sortie d'hospitalisation des
personnes âgées le maintien à domicile
pour ce faire une aide exceptionnelle de
500 euros par mois sera octroyée pour 3
mois minimum aux seniors qui ne sont pas
bénéficiaires de l'allocation personnes
âgées
elle n'a pas cette somme doit leur
permettre de financer des prestations à
domicile des aides à la personne par
ailleurs le versement des appâts sera
maintenu pour les bénéficiaires en mars
et avril sur les mêmes bases qu'en
février
enfin une aide exceptionnelle a été mise
en place pour l'hébergement temporaire
dans les ehpad
je vous en parlais la semaine dernière
des sans abri vont être accueillis en
début de semaine à jouy en josas par
arrêté la préfecture des yvelines a
réquisitionné deux bâtiments de l'ancien
site thalès et dispositifs
supplémentaires en plus de la mise à
disposition de chambres d'hôtels et de
centres d'accueil spécialisés les sans
abri est hébergée présentent tous des
symptômes de covin 19
écoutez les explications de vincent
roberti secrétaire général de la
préfecture des yvelines il est interrogé
par nicolas landry et nicolas
kirillovitch on a augmenté le nombre de
places on a par exemple les 330 places
hivernales
on les a prolongé de deux mois ce qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui dans les yvelines
on a trois mille places pour permettre
d'accueillir les sans abri
effectivement on a mis en place qui va
s'ouvrir dans quelques jours un centre à
jouy en josas
on appelle covit plus mais qui n'est
réservé qu'aux sans abri déjà malade
soit 2 qu'ovide avérés soit de suspicion
de co vide et sait gérer bien sûr par la
rs et les médecins en détention aussi se
pose des problèmes sanitaires avec des
prisons surchargées un exemple à bois
d'arcy on comptait la semaine dernière
neuf cent soixante quatre prisonniers
pour 560 4 places est disponible dans la
maison d'arrêt pour désengorger les
prisons et limiter les risques de
contamination la garde des sceaux nicole
belloubet souhaite que les juges procède
à des libérations anticipées de
personnes condamnées ou en fin de peine
et de réserver la détention aux
individus les plus dangereux dans les
yvelines 133 détenus ont ainsi pu être
relâché la semaine dernière interview de
la procureure de la république de
versailles par nicolas d'andrus il y à
la disposition des juges d'application
des peines des mesures qui existent
d'ailleurs en ce moment comme n'importe
quand dans l'année mais qui ont encore
un peu plus d'importance que sont les
remises de peine exceptionnelle qui font
que et bien la fin de peine d'une
personne détenue pour les bonnes raisons
pour un bon comportement va par exemple
pouvoir lui être octroyé un petit peu
plus vite on réexamine aussi toutes les
personnes qui sont actuellement placé en
régime de semi liberté dont des gens qui
sont libres la journée pour différentes
raisons et qui reviennent en détention
le soir pour évoquer dans quelle mesure
un certain nombre de ces dossiers et
bien peuvent être suspendus c'est à dire
la semi liberté son régime
son exécution est suspendu et sera
reprise éventuellement à la fin de la
période de crise la perte de confinement
quatorzième jour de confinement en
france une mesure qui a été prolongée
pour une durée de deux semaines
supplémentaires minimum afin de se plier
aux recommandations gouvernementales le
trafic du réseau stibus va
progressivement être réduits à partir
d'aujourd'hui à saint quentin en
yvelines une réduction du passage des
bus de l'ordre de moins 80 à moins 95%
selon les lignes et diminution du trafic
d
plus tout comme pour le reste des
transports en commun plus d'informations
via les liens qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran
partons à présent à plus de dix mille
kilomètres des yvelines à lima au pérou
1 yvelinois kevin taurin y est en ce
moment confinées il est parti depuis
plusieurs mois pour un tour du monde à
vélo avec son frère et guillaume et les
aventures des gros que vous suivez et
sans doute sur tv 78 un voyage donc en
pause pour le moment kevin nous raconte
son quotidien et avait 78
nous sommes toujours en plein tour du
monde à vélo mais un arrêt s'est imposé
puisqu'il ya un confinement qui a été
mis en place
ici donc au pérou et halima
particulièrement où nous sommes un
confinement depuis le 16 mars avec un
couvre-feu de 20h à 5h du matin nous
sommes donc en confinement chez un ami
jean georges que nous remercions
énormément pour son aide donc une
situation un peu particulière pour nous
qui avons l'habitude de voyager chaque
jour dans un nouvel endroit une nouvelle
ville nouveau village au pérou faut
savoir qu'il ya actuellement environ 395
cas pour cinq décès et il faut savoir
que le confinement a été mis en place à
peu près à 100 cas on sent que le
péruvien et les habitants du pérou sont
très sensibles à cette problématique
d'autant plus qu'ici services de santé
sont beaucoup moins développé que dans
des pays comme comme chez nous comme en
france donc on sent que ils font vite
concernant ce qui va venir donc du coup
ont tous les jours on apprend de
nouvelles choses ici à lima et on parle
d'un prolongement deux semaines et un
mois
ce qui est intéressant de remarquer du
coup on est dans une capitale et c'est
comme à paris il ya beaucoup de bruit il
ya beaucoup de pollution on se rend
compte qu'il ya beaucoup moins de
circulation
on sent que l'air est beaucoup plus pur
on va dire d'autant plus qu'on est à
côté de la mer du coup nous ce qu'on
espère toute l'équipe est grosse et
qu'on puisse se s'engager tous ensemble
aussi vite que ce confinement ce que ce
problème sanitaire pour l'environnement
je voulais bien évidemment remercier
toute l'équipe de tva 78 qui travaillent
en ces jours de confinement jeu
ils pas les monteurs ni même
l'infographiste merci beaucoup et puis
bah bientôt on espère au tour du monde
ciao que vous soyez confiné en amérique
latine ou bien dans votre logement des
yvelines l'un des casse tête du moment
c'est celui des repas comment équilibrer
comment se faire plaisir alors que
l'activité physique est parfois réduite
est jointe par mélanie poké emilie
démoli et diététicienne nutritionniste
elle nous donne quelques conseils
est ce qu'il ya un régime spécial à
adapter alors un régime spécial adapté
non il n'ya pas de régime adapté
vraiment le mot d'ordre c'est toujours
l'équilibré alimentaire juste adapter
les quantités puisque nos dépenses
énergétiques sont plus les mêmes on a
beaucoup moins de dépenses énergétiques
on va moins se bouger du coup on va
adapter notre assiette sur tous nos
points de vue portion est donc quantité
c'est à dire on va diminuer de combien
de têtes des eaux des conseils
alors on va rester sur une assiette sur
la base un tiers un tiers un tiers un
tiers de légumes un tiers de féculents
un tiers de protéines animales des
protéines animales maigre c'est sûr
qu'on va éviter les pannes hurler
friture à la charcuterie
on va plutôt aller vers des protéines
maigres comme la viande blanche le
poisson du ton du maquereau que l'on
trouve aussi en boîte les légumes et
bien sûr les féculents alors c'est vrai
que les féculents reste des sucres et
c'est en ça c'est ce petit groupe
alimentaire qui va falloir minimisé par
rapport à son quotidien où on aurait
plus de dépenses énergétiques donc
l'apport de riz de pâtes de lentilles
pourquoi avait vraiment petites portions
à chaque repas il faut tout utilisé
justement c'est une situation où on peut
utiliser nos placards nos congélateurs
notre réfrigérateur et donc tout ce qui
est sûr je les noms cuisiné par part
contre acheter plutôt un des protéines
des végétaux à drut en fait nos cuisines
et les concerts donc ce qu'on appelle
les produits appertisés que l'on
retrouve dans des bocaux ou en concerne
sont à utiliser à partir manque c'est
également mon cuisine et donc des petits
pois carottes des coeurs de palmiers des
coeurs d'artichauts des haricots verts
des haricots beurre des flageolets du
des pois chiches donc toutes ces sources
la à partir du moment où c'est acheter
brut et non cuisinés sont les bienvenus
dans nos paniers dans nos placards et
dans nos réfrigérateurs bien sûr de
telle manière à avoir toujours cet
apport de légumes secs ou bien sûr de
végétaux et pourquoi pas de protéines
animales puisqu'on retrouve beaucoup de
poissons de bons poissons gras comme le
thon le maquereau les sardines harengs
en conserve et si par cette voie de
confinement ou le moral peut baisser
aussi parfois ce qu'on a droit de faire
un petit écart
bien sûr bien sûr on va pas diaboliser
les aliments à risque ou les aliments ce
qu'on appelle les aliments plaisir
justement puisqu'on est en famille mais
c'est s'autoriser s'octroyer si on peut
être si je peux dire une fois ou deux
par semaine
que ce soit un petit à un moment
apéritif ou un brunch un matin on a là
on n'a plus un peu plus de temps pour
certains le week-end est difficile de
pratiquer le sport en ce moment pour
s'entretenir l'autorisation de
déplacement dérogatoire vous autorise la
pratique du footing pour une heure
maximum et dans un rayon d'un kilomètre
autour de votre domicile de nombreuses
infrastructures sportives sont donc à
l'arrêt c'est le cas du gofle du golf
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
située à guyancourt accueil practice
parcours et restaurants sont fermés au
public paul hermitage et le directeur du
golf national
bonjour à toutes et à tous du golf
national
nous voulions prend la parole pour vous
dire
un grand bonjour déjà et ô combien vous
nous manquez notre golf n'est pas pareil
sans vous c'est clair nos abonnés nos
clients du monde entier
mais je suis certain que les conditions
quand vous allez revenir vont être
absolument incroyable en tout cas nos
jardiniers font tout pour en ce moment
avec les aérations les travaux
mécaniques mais aussi les entretiens
normaux du parcours les tentes etc
quand vous pouvez voir derrière moi sur
le green du 18 wagons sans vous c'est
pas pareil mais cette période nécessaire
de confinement pour nous protéger et
protéger notre santé va aussi nous
permettre de se rendre compte quelle
chance nous golfeurs avant de pratiquer
ce sport magnifique un mois un mois et
demi de pause c'est désespérant quand on
est drogué du golfe mais aussi j'espère
que tout le monde reviendra avec la
conviction que nous sommes des chanceux
et que un sport en plein air comme ça il
n'y a rien de mieux
en tout cas toutes les équipes sont à
l'oeuvre en vidéoconférence quasiment
quotidiennement plus les jardiniers à
l'oeuvre à l'extérieur tous les jours
pour vous préparer une rentrée dès qu'on
peut avec tout ce qu'il vous faut pour
être les plus heureux du monde
voilà donc à très bientôt nous espérons
nombreux évidemment mais aussi avec le
sourire comme d'habitude comme et notre
signature au golf national
à très bientôt et merci ce pourrait être
le cas pour d'autres sports le rugby
amateur ne reprendra pas cette saison
décision de la fédération française de
rugby
en conséquence aucun titre de champion
de france ni de champion de ligue ne
sera décerné pour la saison 2010 9 2020
les modalités relatives aux accessions
et aux éventuelle relégation elles
seront communiquées d'ici le 3 avril
indique la ffr mais pas de panique un la
pratique sportive à domicile est tout de
même possible les éducateurs sportifs de
la ville de trappes vous donne en ce
moment quelques conseils première séance
à regarder
von trapp silwan éducateurs sportifs de
la ville
nous avons décidé de mettre à
disposition son réseau une série de
vidéos courtes qui vous aidera à garder
la forme et le rythme le but de ces
vidéos et de faire une idée
d'entraînement a réalisé bien évidemment
chez vous seul ou entre amis
l'objectif aujourd'hui est de brûler un
maximum de calories c'est parti alors le
circuit se compose de quatre exercices
et joe 12 minutes à réaliser un maximum
de fonds exercice sans leur fils jérôme
et aux soucis et jacques 6-2 30 noms des
jeunes aux métiers rythme et on pousse
bien concret exercice 3 disques watts
ok le point sur l'état des forces les
abdos le dos bien droit et en expirant
longtemps exercice 4 25 punch hockey
cherche bien la contraction n'oublie pas
de souffler ok je capitule gibert peas
30 montées de genoux
j squat et 25 crunch à réaliser un
maximum de tours possibles pendant 12
minutes
quant à nous on se retrouve très vite
pour nous
vidéo prenez soin de vous et chez nous
c'est la fin de cette édition spéciale
merci de votre fidélité on se quitte sur
ces images l'autoroute a12 presque
déserte en ce lundi 30 mars un axe
d'ordinaire saturé aux heures de pointe
rester à la maison et très belle soirée
sur tv 78
[Musique]